okay
welcome to the ddps seminar everyone uh
before we introduce our invited speaker
let's go over some rules and logistics
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk unless
you have questions
if you have questions you are welcome to
mute and ask otherwise please use chat
room to post your questions so that we
can address them in q a
session at the end
second today's ddps seminar is open to
external audiences and therefore no
classified discussion is allowed so
please watch out finally the talk today
will be recorded
and uploaded in our youtube channel well
that's about it now let me introduce our
speaker today
it is an honor to host uh benjamin
pierstoffer who is an assistant
professor at current institute of
mathematical science since 2018
he was a postdoctoral associate in the
aerospace computational design
laboratory at the massachusetts
institute of technology working with
professor karen wilcox
he received his ph.d degree from the
technical university of munich in
germany
benjamin's research focuses on
computational methods for data and
compute
intensive
science and engineering applications
including scientific machine learning
mathematics of data science model
reductions and computational statistics
today benjamin will talk about neural
gauging schemes with active learning for
high dimensional evolution equations now
without further ado let me
press the button to benjamin by asking
our usual question that is what is your
favorite things to do other than
research
all right so thank you very much for the
nice introduction and
especially thanks for the invitation to
this really interesting seminar series
so i will focus today on non-linear
parameterizations for pde solutions and
i especially want to focus on training
aspects so how can we numerically find
nonlinear parametrization such as deep
networks that well approximate say our
pde solution and i will focus on wave
propagation problems or problems in
higher dimensions where there's a
coherent structure that moves through
the spatial domain
and what i will try to convince you is
that active learning can really help us
in tackling these kind of problems when
it comes to training for wave
propagation high dimensional problems
transport dominated problems
now before i start let me acknowledge my
two collaborators on this work ashore
and bruno and eric von and iden who are
both
faculty at quran as well
okay so as i said i'm interested in the
following in transport dominated
problems and
one example of transport dominated
problems are wave propagation
here you can see something that could be
simulated with for example shallow water
equations where there's a wave that is
traveling through some spatial domain
over time but there are many other wave
pro many other transfer dominated
problems for example later we will talk
about particle systems
what i'm showing here is the position of
a particle one versus particle four
versus position of particle eight so the
more particles they are the higher
dimensional that problem becomes
and what we're interested in is
understanding the density of the
particles as it changes over time as the
particles get attracted by the trap and
what happens there is that at first the
particle density is quite broad it has a
high variance but then as the particles
get attracted by the trap it gets more
concentrated and then we are then we
need to predict a high dimensional peak
as it travels through the high
dimensional domain
another
example where we have transport
dominated phenomena that we have to
numerically simulate is when we want to
look at particles in plasma so one of um
students that is working with me freddie
law
he is uh co-advised with antoine zephan
who is the plasma expert and they are
really interested in understanding how
particles move in say fusion devices
whether these particles are lost over
time when they are lost what is the
ratio that they are lost those kind of
things
another effort that i'm involved in is
numerical simulations of chemical
reacting flows and i'm showing you here
a movie by by chang huang who has done a
lot of work on modern reduction and also
full models in that direction and the
challenging transport dominated problem
there is that there are pressure waves
that travel through for example
combustion chambers
so in all those problems there's some
transport happening and we would like to
numerically simulate those problems for
example many times in a row for
different parameters over long time
ranges or for different initial
conditions say in a design loop or an
uncertainty modification
so one way we could achieve that is
classical model reduction where the idea
is to find some latent dynamics that can
well describe the potentially much
higher dimensional transport dynamics
and to make it a little bit more precise
let's let's formalize this and let's say
we have given an evolution equation
where we have here
our time derivative and the solution q
at time t and spatial coordinate x and
then we have a right hand side function
f that depends on the solution that
depends on time and that depends on the
spatial coordinate and the spatial
domain is omega in the following
now if we say we would like to find
latent dynamics then a first step could
be to try to understand what are the
possible solutions that we might visit
over time and for this the model
reduction community is really interested
in studying these sets of of possible
solutions they are called solution
manifolds which are subsets of high
dimensional solution spaces think of
finite element spaces or with a fine
mesh fine grid of capital n dimension
and then this curly m is the is a subset
of that space that contains all possible
solutions that are visited in a certain
time range
and the idea of classical model
reduction is to say can we find a low
dimensional subspace curly v little n so
little n is much smaller than the
capital n so the dimension of the
original subspace can one find such a
low dimensional subspace in which to
approximate well all the elements of
that solution manifold and the
underlying idea is that one says if one
would plot this high dimensional
solution space and if it only had three
dimensions and one would plot the
solutions over time as dots in that
space then they should not be scattered
all over the solution space but they
should form smooth low dimensional very
low dimensional manifolds
more from an empirical perspective we
could say we collect snapshots snapshots
are just the coefficients vectors of the
representations in these high
dimensional approximation spaces and one
takes those snapshots and puts them as
columns in a snapshot matrix and then
one can observe the decay of the
singular values of that snapshot matrix
q and if they decay quickly then one can
find a low dimensional space to well
represent or well approximate the
columns so the snapshots and if they
decay slowly then this is this is not
necessarily the case
so that the overall idea is to first
drain find a low dimensional subspace
curly v little n that approximates well
all elements that one can possibly find
by solving that pde over time or
different parameters and then this is a
one time high cost step and then online
or in the evaluation phase one
approximates the high dimensional
solution in this low dimensional space
to construct a reduced solution q-tilde
which has fewer degrees of freedoms and
therefore one
can achieve speed ups in in many
situations so this is really classical
material just to set the stage here and
i'm giving you here textbooks and
classical survey papers on that topic if
you want to dive deeper into that into
that literature
okay so let's apply now this
standard setting to uh two toy examples
the first one is the heat equation in
just a one-dimensional domain we have
here the spatial domain one-dimensional
and time and there's a nonzero right
hand side and this is what we get um how
this how the solution behaves over time
for the heat equation here now i'm
collecting snapshots so i'm over time
i'm equidistant time i'm collecting
snapshots and put them into my snapshot
matrix and i'm plotting the singular
values versus the number of modes or the
index of the singular value here on the
x-axis
and i'm using
i think 512
grid points to discretize the heat
equation and you can see the singular
values indicate that with maybe 20 modes
one can up to double precision perfectly
represent at least the snapshots that i
have collected so there is some kind of
low rank low dimensional structure in
there that classical model reduction
could could indeed exploit
another toy example is advection pure
advection where one starts again here's
the spatial domain time and one starts
with a localized initial condition
here for example just a gaussian bump
and then the only thing that that linear
advection equation is doing it
transports that gaussian bump through
the spatial domain so there's no
diffusion there's not really much
happening except that the initial
condition is just transported to the
left here
if we now collect snapshots on these
for these for this problem over time and
we plot the singular values of the
corresponding snapshot matrix so
singular value versus number of modes
then you already can see a very
different behavior there's even a
different rate of how these singular
values decay and
um you can also see that many more modes
so much higher dimensional subspaces
would be required to even represent the
the snapshots that that i have collected
here so this these two toy examples
should just motivate that there is a
difference or that there can be a
difference between the type of physics
in some sense that we would like to
approximate whether these classical
model reduction methods work well or
whether there might be some issues with
trying to find subspaces and this
motivates now the outline of my
presentation i would first like to
convince you that indeed for these
transport dominated problems we need
some kind of nonlinear parametrization
this could be deep networks but this
could be other nonlinear
parametrizations
and that we can fairly often fairly
easily write down normally
parametrizations that work well but
that's only half of the story the other
half of the story is really numerically
working with these nonlinear
parametrizations
and for this there is
quite some work around but i will try to
convince you that
our proposal neuroglucan schemes
has some benefits in the sense that it
can be very easily coupled with an
active learning scheme which um
turns out in the numerical experiments
that we did is quite a is quite uh
important for wave propagation problems
where there's some local dynamics that
travel through the spatial domain which
are exactly the problems that motivate
us for for looking at nonlinear
parametrizations in the first place and
i have some numerical experiments in in
lower dimensions but also more
importantly in higher dimensions that um
hopefully convince you about that
okay so let me dive into the need for
nonlinear parametrizations
um and if you are more if you're
interested in in this general topic i
was recently invited to write a an
educational or survey article about
nonlinear parameterizations in model
reduction if you are interested to dive
a bit deeper and have some more
references then i would encourage you to
have a look at these this article that
appeared in the notices of the american
mathematical society just in this dismay
issue
okay so we said classical mod reduction
is trying to approximate elements on
this in this set of possible solutions
the solution manifold
and um
one way to understand how well a space
can approximate the elements in that in
that set of possible solutions is via
the kolmogorov n with there are many
variants of how to define a kolmogorov
and with and
different variants of it i'm just
showing you here one as an as an example
this e little and curly m where the
curly m is the set of elements we want
to approximate and a little n is the
dimension of the subspace in which we
want to approximate these elements and
what this d n curly m is doing is says
let's pick the best space of dimension n
the best subspace of dimension n so that
in the worst case picking the worst
element of the set of elements we want
to approximate this this does best so
it's kind of a worst case
best selection of the of the space
now there are some results that uh
describe for certain classes of pdes how
does kolmogorov end with the case with
the dimension n it's uh typically quite
challenging to find a space that exactly
minimizes that chroma growth and with
but um there are some bounds that tell
us how this end width should decay as we
increase the dimension of the subspace
so these are existence results and one
of those is for example for a symmetric
cursive elliptic pdes from 2002 and
there's a
has been extended in many ways in this
2016 paper due to similar types of of
problems
but these are mostly existence results
so they tell us there exists spaces that
achieve an exponential decay
of this
of this chromograph in with the the
other side of the coin that we have to
look at are the numerics and also for
for that side of the coin there are
methods there are works available that
show that reduced spaces low dimensional
subspaces actually can be numerically
constructed that achieve that
exponential error decay
so for these kind of problems symmetric
cursive elliptic um
roughly speaking one can say that the
kolmogorov end with
decays exponentially which is a very
good news for a classical mod reduction
um i would even more
fussy say for diffusion-dominated
problems these classical mod reduction
techniques work quite well and it also
agrees with the numerical observation of
the toy example that i have shown
earlier at least the singular values
decay quickly as well for for something
like the integration
okay so these are diffusion dominated
problems now for the transport dominated
problems kind of the other class that
we're interested in
here a prototypical example is the
linear advection equation we will see
that example a few times moving forward
so this is the time derivative we have
the spatial derivative of first order we
have a left boundary condition and the
initial condition is just a step
function so the only thing that is
happening here is that over the spatial
domain this step function is transported
over time
and what has been shown for this
specific setup so with this boundary
condition and this initial condition
obergendrav in 2016 have shown that this
column of end with cannot decay faster
than one over square root n
so we have seen this exponential error
decay for i would say diffusion
dominated problems on the previous slide
and now for this transfer dominated
problems we see there cannot exist a
space that gives us a faster error decay
than one over square root n which is
quite a quite limiting when you think of
the exponential error decay the
classical model reduction would like to
see
and these kind of lower bounds
have not only be derived for exactly
this specific setup but there are also
other results for example for certain
setups of the wave equation by grife and
urban in 2020 that also show lower
bounds of that of that type one over
square root n in in any case much much
slower than the exponential decay for
diffusion dominating problems so there
indeed is also not only on the numerical
observation that we had made earlier but
also on the more theoretical side one
can really show that there is a
difference in how these problems can
perform with classical
model reduction methods
okay so this is um
bad news but it's also in some sense
good news so first it is bad news
because it tells us if we want to do
something like in classical model
reduction then we take a linear
approximation then the error really is
bounded by what this chromograph end
with
tells us so there's this so-called
chromograph end with barrier
and the reason is that these are really
linear approximations so what i mean by
that in the following is that the
subspace in which one approximates the
elements of this curly m set um that
those
subspaces are fixed which then means
that the linear combination that is our
reduced solution depends on the
parameter beta or the coefficient beta
which changes with time and it depends
on these basis functions phi i that only
depend on the spatial coordinate
so if we would write this ma more in a
machine learning style we would get
maybe something like this where now beta
is our parameter that we allow to change
that we allow to to fit based on the
element that we want to approximate and
that beta enters linearly in the
approximation that we use here for as
our reduced approximation so the beta
transpose the dot product times say the
basis matrix or even let's say a kernel
matrix or something like this
okay so this is the bad news that these
kind of approximations really cannot
work well in
for these transport dominated problems
the good news is that one can work
around this by coming up with different
types of approximations and the first
direction at least from the model
reduction perspective the first
attempts in in terms of nonlinear
approximations were localized methods so
these were maybe early 2010s where the
idea was to
compute not only one subspace but to
pre-compute multiple subspaces all of
these subspaces clearly v1 the curly v j
are spent by a different set of basis
functions and then depending on some
indicator one selects one of those space
in which one wants to approximate the
current element of the solution manifold
so often these indicators depend on time
so that at different time slices you
pick a different space in which to
approximate these indicators could also
depend on a parameter um they could
depend on some input they could depend
on some
the state variable the reduced state
variable many many options are possible
here the key thing is that the space in
which one approximate changes with the
element one wants to approximate and
this is this is this is then gives you a
non-linear approximation so now in some
sense the representation in which we
want to approximate our solution changes
depending on which element we want to
approximate
and there's lots of work in that
direction from the model reduction
perspective it's also very closely
related to dictionary approaches in
compressed sensing and many other
many many other communities so i'm just
giving you here the model reduction
perspective and i'm listing here several
works that that have contributed to that
to that literature
okay so instead of localized one could
say we would like to adapt spaces so now
the space curley v n depends on time t
which means that it is spanned by n
basis functions that change with time
that we allow to adapt and change with
time
and then we approximate our element from
curly m our
high dimensional solution in this
adaptive space which is still a linear
combination so the beta enters linearly
but now the phi
depends on time which also means we not
only need to propagate forward the
solution over time we also need to
propagate forward the basis so one also
needs to adapt the basis from time t to
time t plus delta t with some update
and in this direction of online adaptive
model reduction there also has been
quite some work over the last um 10 15
years maybe especially dynamic low rank
approximations by cork and lubic in 2007
but also the really fundamental work by
tme subsyst in 2009 has spawned a series
of papers on on that topic
there's work on on basis propagation and
we have done some work on adapting the
spaces from spa samples to do this in an
online efficient way and there's also
lots of work on enriching subspaces
especially the work by carl berg that
can give some guarantees on how well
this can do
so this this brought us from linear
approximations having one fixed space do
localized model reduction that has
multiple precomputed spaces to adaptive
model reduction where we have one space
but we adapt it over time so we also
have an evolution of the of the basis
and this is actually the challenging
part how to do the evolution of the
bases efficiently
now we can take a step further and say
we not only want our
basis functions to change with time we
just would like that our representation
of the solution depends on some feature
vector alpha that we are allowed to
adapt as well so i'm calling this alpha
in the following the n prime many
components say and now the
reduced solution looks like this where
we have here the spatial coordinate x we
have still the parameter beta but now we
additionally have the feature alpha the
beta and this linearly and the feature
can change the the basis function the
representation in which we want to
approximate our our high dimensional
solution
so this adapts the representation to the
target q via the feature vectors alpha
and for the purpose of this presentation
only um this is what really what deep
networks are about from that perspective
so again i want to repeat from that
perspective this is what uh what deep
networks um yd networks are useful for
approximating these kind of problems in
the following there are many other good
reasons for using the networks but for
us here having these features and
allowing them to change the
representation is really what makes them
a useful tool here
okay so this is a fairly general
representation or parametrization of
course to work with these kind of things
one has to be more concrete and and
describe how this is parameterized um
in machine learning speech that would be
the network architecture um we can also
ask the question of how well does this
approximation do one can often fairly
quickly show that it can do better than
than what the kolmogorov barrier gives
us but what really the best
approximation error is of these kind of
parametrizations is quite challenging to
achieve especially in in
for finite settings
but what i'm interested in the following
is modern numerics so given such a
parametrization how can we now
numerically compute with it how can we
find beta and alpha such that the
corresponding q tilde such that the
corresponding network function is a is a
a reasonable approximation of our pde
solution and as you are very well aware
and this seminar series is one example
there's very active research um going on
in that direction there's no hope that i
can list even a small subset of all the
works that relevant that's relevant here
but by just looking through the names
here you can already see several of the
speakers that have talked in that in
that seminar series here already
okay so we would like to numerically
work with these nonlinear
parametrizations now and there are
various ways of doing this and one very
prominent one is a collocation-based
approach
so there let's now combine this the
features and the coefficients paid into
just one generic parameter theta that
our nonlinear parametrization depends on
so if you have a deep network this could
be the biases and the weights
and then one
widely used approach that works very
well in many situations is to say we
would like that our network
parameterizes our solution over time and
space so both time and the spatial
coordinate are inputs to the network
to approximate the solution function and
they depend on one large set of of
weights and and other parameters
and the idea then is to say one draw
samples over the time space domain so t
x pairs let's say m many of those based
on some distribution
over the time space domain and then one
fits the parameter theta by minimizing
the pde residual at those sampling
points and again this has been very
successful in in many many situations
and and worked really well
um in the setting of that we are
interested in here especially wave
propagation problems something where
where something local coherent moving
maybe to even a high dimensional domain
this can be these settings this time
space collocation methods can become
challenging and i would like to
demonstrate this again on on this toy
example of the linear erection equation
where we have only a one-dimensional
spatial domain versus time
and we have an initial condition that is
very local in the spatial domain so this
is often what we see in transport
dominated problems and now what happens
in in
transport dominated problems in general
in that in that example in particular is
that this initial condition gets
transported through the spatial domain
now if we now try to fit uh our
nonlinear parametrization based on tx
pairs on time space collocation points
to that solution then we have to sample
a space that looks like this so a domain
that looks like this this is the
one-dimensional spatial domain of the
problem and this is the one-dimensional
time domain of that problem and what you
can see is that the region where
actually something is happening here is
very small compared to the overall
volume of that of that domain
so if one just draws now in an
uninformed way samples to fit the
parameters then many of those samples
for example with just a uniform
distribution will fall in regions where
not much as much is happening and one
really needs to draw many many samples
to do to to hit this local structure um
where actually the pde shows us some
some dynamics and in in one spatial
domain and one time domain one might be
able to do that but think now spatial
domains in two in three dimensions where
something like a peak is traveling
through a domain then you can can
already see that this can become
computationally quite challenging and if
if you even now go to higher dimensions
where we have our particle systems that
live in eight dimensions or even higher
dimensions and there's a peak density
that is traveling through the domain
then this essentially boils down to
trying to find with an uninformed
sampling a peaked function in a high
dimensional domain which which really is
computationally quite expensive
so based on on that observation
this is what brings us now to
neuroglurkin schemes which
allow us to look at training of the
networks from a different perspective a
more a numerical analysis perspective
and what's really important for us is
that distance directly links to the
active learning part that allows us to
select samples at which to minimize the
residual in a more informed way
okay so let me let me go to do this
neural looking scheme now so what we do
there is that we say we still have our
solution of our potential pde but now we
parametrize that solution not in time
and space together but only in the
spatial coordinate
and this means now that the parameter
theta depends on time and the network
has would if it is a network or some
other nonlinear parametrization has this
input only the spatial coordinate x and
if we want to propagate forward in time
then we have to find a different
different parameter vector or different
parameter function
and again in terms of network this would
mean the rates depend on time and we
have to update the weights over time as
we go through as we propagate through
time
so this is the setup that we would like
to to consider now and we would like to
solve a time dependent pde where we now
plug in our our nonlinear
parametrization
here q which now depends on this
parameter theta which itself depends on
time and the spatial coordinate and the
right hand side f depends on time x and
again the solution and notice that time
now enters only through the parameter
theta here so the way we can push
forward our nonlinear parametrization in
time is by updating its parameters
okay
what we now would like to do is try to
understand
what dynamics are there on this
parameters theta for a given pde
so instead of fitting this theta t with
a big optimization problem and and say
sgd or something we would like to
understand um if you want to numerically
solve in some sense that we'll make
precise in a second if you want to
numerically solve our pde now
what what dynamics do we have on our
theta t how do we need to update our
theta t over time
and for this
let's write down the residual this is
the residual here i take the time
derivative the chain rule you have here
the gradient of the solution and then
here that the theta dot but
formally it's not defined yet so i just
call it ether and here we have the right
hand side f and then i formulate an
objective j
that depends on theta and eta where i
just integrate the squared residual
against the mesh nu t
there are now two things that are
interesting in that objective the first
one is that this objective depends on
time
so at each point in time we get a
different objective that we want to
minimize
and the measure against we integrate our
squared residual is allowed to change
with time as well
and this will be critical for later
because this already points to that we
later need to sample from that measure
nu t to numerically estimate that
integral over the squared residual and
by allowing to adapt the measure over
time it allows us to select sampling
points
different sampling points over time and
we can adapt the sampling points to
parts of the of the spatial domain where
actually things are happening where it
is important to actually minimize the
squared residual
so this is this is really different from
from a time space discretization
perspective
okay so we have our objective and now we
would like to minimize it over all times
so at each time point we would like to
minimize it and get our theta dot
and we we can achieve that in in in the
sense of setting the gradient of our
objective to zero and this gives us now
equations that tell us how to theta dot
the time derivative of the weights how
they have to change over time and this
is this is given by the system of odes
here where we have this m operator that
i will define in a second
and where we have a right hand side f
that depends on time that depends on the
parameters and it is a system of odes
for the theta dot so for the time
derivative of the of the rates
so in that sense if we now manage to
push forward the rates of our network
following these system dynamics
then
it means that the corresponding network
function in the
residual minimizing sense
numerically solves the pde that we have
written down earlier
this is this is the idea so instead of
fitting parameters say with one large
optimization problem we have turned here
finding the parameters to solving a
system of odes
and i really want to point out that
similar things have been done in in
various flavors in in other settings
such as this work by do and sucky on
evolutional dnns where they formulate a
very similar system of odes but they
mostly look at low dimensional problems
without the active learning part that
that will be quite critical for us there
is a work by black hunger and um and
schultz
who have done something for more
transformations there is some other work
wonder on the model reduction side
there's work by anderson and and
collaborators on also tailored nonlinear
parametrizations that can be used and
for which similar systems can be derived
so again for us this is one component it
allows us now to update rates over time
instead of finding weights globally over
time and space this is this is the key
thing for us
okay so we ended up with this system of
of odes and now we are back to classical
numerical analysis in
in some some respect namely we need to
numerically solve now that system of
odes so we can discretize it in time um
we take k time steps um t 0 is is
initial time step and t k is the final
time step and we can have adaptive time
step sizes so we can even adapt how the
time step size over time and we can
discretize this kind of system with
implicit explicit schemes and all the
classical numerical analysis aspects now
apply to that to that system here as
well and the overall picture that you
should keep in mind is that now the
network is strained time sliced by time
slice over time as in the classical
method of lines approaches that we are
very familiar with from from scientific
computing and from from numerical
analysis
okay so this m and f
operators they are defined like this and
you can work this out fairly easily and
when you when you follow that the steps
that i mentioned earlier and you find
similar operators in in other settings
so in when we do to explain the name
when we look at a network that has a
special structure for example like this
so q is our approximation it depends on
a on a vector of parameters it has a
linear output layer that with weights
beta and the
the defy other say the units or um can
also can also be a deeper network that
is a standard output layer
and the alpha are the features
if you look at the network in that form
then one can show that this m and f
correspond to a galerkin projection at
time t of the residual um against these
phi's and their derivatives with respect
to the smashing nu t that potentially
changes over time so this is why we have
chosen this neuroglurkin term here
okay we can discretize the system of
odes with various schemes i want to call
out one one interesting observation and
that is that there's a real difference
between explicit and implicit schemes
that we are again very familiar with
from a scientific computing or numerical
analysis side if we choose an explicit
scheme so say a runge-kutta 4-5 scheme
or just the wrong encoder for scheme or
even forward euler as in this case here
then at each point in time we only have
to solve a linear regression problem or
a linear system of equations so at each
point in time the cost per time step is
actually very low when you think of we
have here nonlinear parametrization
where we push the parameters forward
over time
in contrast if we take an implicit
scheme because for example it is
prescribed by the pde that we have
there's some some stiffness or something
like this then we get a system of
nonlinear equations at each time step
and we have to solve corresponding the
system of nonlinear equations at each
time step this is so the time that the
cost per time step is more expensive but
we potentially can take larger steps
which is again very similar to what we
know from from classical numerical
analysis and at least i always feel a
bit more comfortable when things
can be related to something that we that
we understand um that we understand very
well
okay
so this is this this is the setup now
again um for us the key aspect is that
we can push forward the network
parameters now over time based on the
dynamics that that are described by the
pde
and this brings me now to the active
learning part because so far i have not
really mentioned how we can actually get
this m and f
so m and f are these two
operators in finite dimensions they are
matrices that define the system dynamics
of the of the parameters theta
and what they are are expected values
with raspberry do not measure new t
and
of sum of some target function here and
f also an expected value with respect to
this measure nu t of some target
function includes the right hand side of
the of the pde here now just as in
classical finite elements
in certain situations by taking a
specific network architecture by having
a specific pde we can write down this m
and f analytically so for the finite
dimensional case we can analytically
write down the entries of the of the
matrix elements this is again
analogous to what we see in finite
elements where again for say the heat
equation and linear elements we can
write down the entries of the
mass and stiffness matrix
in more general settings though we have
to do something numerically we have to
do an estimation step or some
approximation step and one way that one
could approach this is via monte carlo
so drawing samples
of our measure nu t so new at time t
and these samples are x one t k to x m t
k and then taking a monte carlo
estimator of this m and f with
little m many samples
and here you can see now why it's
important that this measure nu t is
allowed to depend on time because now
the samples that we draw with which we
estimate the m at time t k are allowed
to change they are allowed to depend on
time because they are coming from that
measure nu t from that distribution nu t
at time t k
and this allows us to adapt these these
samples to where things are happening
where we actually need to sample and you
can get a very similar monte carlo
estimator for the for the f to get an f
tilde
okay
so with this
with this time dependence and because we
we push forward the parameters the
network parameters over time it allows
us now to use information from say the
previous time step to inform where to
take samples in the next time step and
one very easy
i shouldn't say easy but one
straightforward approach is to say
to sample
proportional to the solution at the
previous time step squared
so this this means samples are taken
there where something is happening in
the solution so where there's a
variation in solution there we take
samples and those that those samples we
then ultimately want to minimize our
residual
and this is this is as i said quite
important in higher dimensions where we
cannot afford to sample globally over
time and space in an extensive way but
now we can sample here based for example
on the solution at the previous time
step sample in regions we already know
something is is happening there
so this neuroglurgen idea of adapting
the parameters over time step by step
allows us to
allows us to combine this with this
active learning idea of adapting where
the samples are based on the solution of
the previous time step so this is in
some sense self-informed self-guided
based on what we have seen in the past
and what i will do in the following is
look at one specific active learning
scheme which is a very simple one we're
currently working on various extensions
to
various extensions but they are not
ready yet to to be presented so what i
will do in the following is i will look
at networks of this type when we look at
higher dimensional problems of this type
where we have a unit these are shallow
networks of little and many nodes we
have coefficients beta
and we have a unit phi which is just an
exponential with some some sort of an
exponential and this then allows us to
very quickly
sample in regions where something is
happening in the solution namely by
saying we take those exponentials and
form just a mixture of gaussians with
equal weight
and take that as our measure nu t at
time t
so that the features
of the solution change
the position and the bandwidth of our
gaussian and therefore are pushed around
in directions where the pde solution is
and then we draw samples in that region
by sampling from the corresponding
mixture of gaussians with equal weights
as well
so a very simple approach very cheap to
sample from that
if we have a network architecture like
this and i think it's not too surprising
that
of course certain choices of network
architecture
architectures make it easier for us to
sample versus um
versus make it harder for us to sample
okay so this this combines these two
components the
looking at the problem from time slides
to the next time slice and combining
this with active learning so that we
know where to minimize the residual over
time in a self-guided way
so let me now
go to some numerical experiments
um first one-dimensional ones just
benchmarks that we usually test things
on so for example the quad directive
freeze equation kdv equation where we
use periodic boundary conditions the
room we could do 4 5 time discretization
so we are allowed to adapt the time the
time size
time step size over time and because
this is 1d i just look at a uniform
sampling for now the higher dimensional
problems are coming in a second we're
looking at shallow networks for now with
exponential units that are composed with
a sign to make them periodic and you can
see the solution here we have an
analytic solution to compare to
something so this is the solution with a
spatial domain there are two solid ones
they um
we see that in a second they merge and
then they they
separate again
okay and if we now um use our nonlinear
parametrization to approximate such kind
of a pde solution then we have first
here the truth so against spatial domain
versus time we have here truth because
we have an analytic solution this is
what a linear galerkin approach would
give you where the features are fixed
where you have one space in which you
approximate
it captures the the rough behavior but
the occurrence is not really high and
with neuro glucan with the same number
of degrees of freedoms but it allows us
to adapt the features that the solution
is more accurate by just looking at it
here in the eyeball node okay so this
this is for example another benchmark
example that i wanted to mention for for
completeness is ellen khan which is also
something that's looked at quite often
we have the aquatic potential and the
only
semi different um thing in that setup is
that we have a coefficient in in front
of the the potential such that um
that changes with time in the spatial
coordinate x and what that means is that
when we look at the solution over the
spatial domain then there's this wall
front that moves through the spatial
domain and this is because of this of
this coefficient
we use here a deep network with 10h
units and three layers
and the results that we get uh the
following we have here again our
benchmark this is time versus the
spatial domain
and you can see at first there are three
regimes um
red blue and gray and over time the blue
one fades out this is this bump that you
have seen it gets gets faded out if you
take a linear golurkin approach where we
have the same number of degrees of
freedom as in oracle we can but the
features are fixed there um
this uh this third regime cannot fade
out it's not enough enough
expressiveness here whereas the neural
working gives a reasonable approximation
and you can also see this when you look
at the relative error over time that the
green the three layer neural network
gives a more accurate approximation than
what a linear global approximation would
give
okay now these are all
kind of benchmark examples that i don't
want to spend too much time on really
the thing that we are more interested in
a higher dimensional problems and
especially where something local is
happening over the
in the spatial domain
so here what i'm looking at is a high
dimensional advection equation where now
the coefficient in front of the
advection changes with time so depending
on time
the wave speed changes and you can see
this when you look at the marginals of
this five dimensional problem this is
marginal dimension one two three four
five and you can see depending on in
which dimension we are because of this
coefficient in front of it different
things are happening and the other thing
that you can immediately see is that the
solution the solution is very local in
the spatial domain so it's a very
localized dynamics are happening here um
in this in this five-dimensional domain
we use runge-kutta for five time
integration
and we use our shallow network
architecture with an exponential unit um
to represent the solution so these are
the results that we that we obtain the
first row is the truth we again have an
analytic solution for that example this
is time versus dimension 1 2 3 4 5.
the next row is what we get with a
uniform sampling so an uninformed
sampling the same network so the same
expressiveness in a nonlinear
parametrization but we are not careful
with the training then we have here
again time versus dimension one two
three four five and you can see there's
no hope with just uh looking at the
residual at thousand sampling points in
that five dimensional domain to to
really capture the dynamics that
are
that are given by the corresponding pde
if instead we do our active learning or
adaptive sampling approach then with
again a thousand samples you can see it
can capture quite well what is going on
here in the in the pde
and again the reason this works here
there is no magical so the reason that
this works is that we draw samples and
that we minimize the residual in in
regions where actually things are
happening where something is changing
and therefore it makes sense to to look
at the residual
there okay another example that's a bit
more driven by physics is this particle
example we have now eight particles so
this is an eight dimensional problem and
the position of the particles are
governed by an sde
that chorus and the corresponding
particles
are attracted by a trap that moves with
with time so you will see a behavior
like this and i've shown this plot
earlier this is the position of particle
1 versus particle four versus particle
eight and you can see at first particles
are kind of spread out and then they get
attracted to the trap and then oscillate
in that time varying trap
what we want to approximate is not only
the position of the particles we want to
approximate the whole density of the
particles which is governed by the focal
blank equations in eight dimensions in
this case
and the challenging part here is that at
first the density is quite broad has a
high variance
and then it concentrates over time and
we need to predict this this peak
density and how it oscillates over time
okay so here now
the numerical predictions of the
particle positions for different
combinations of particles so i'm showing
here the position of particle one versus
position of particle four versus
position of particle eight
here particle one versus two versus
three
and here particle six versus seven
versus eight
what i have here is a benchmark solution
for that setting what we can derive is
the mean particle position um only the
mean particle position so not the
density but only the mean particle
position
based on an ode
and these are the black dots so this is
what we would like to match and let's
first have a look at the blue one which
is again using a network but just a
uniform sampling for training for
adapting the weights and you can see
again no hope that the blue one predicts
in any way what uh what a black what the
black uh gives us a benchmark so again
the training is really the the
bottleneck here if we do our adaptive or
active learning approach where we draw
samples in regions where things are
happening
to minimize the residual then you can
see the orange is quite close on top of
the of the black one in all these
situations so it gives us a reasonable
prediction of the mean particle position
over time
we can also see this when we look at the
error this is the error of the mean
particle position versus time and you
can see in orange the
adaptive or active learning approach
which gives an error of about 10 to -3
and in blue you can see just an
uninformed uniform sampling where the
error relative error is is
greater than one
on the right you can see the
approximation of the covariance of the
particle density this is again time
versus the relative error and there are
now two regimes there is first off
diagonal elements they give us an error
of about 10 to the minus one and then
there are the diagonal elements that we
can predict with an error of about 10 or
minus 2. so the off diagonal elements
are quite challenging to approximate in
that case because they are they are
really small
now we not only have the particle
position now we also have the particle
density and so we can do much more than
just looking at particle positions
and one thing we can do is we can
compute multiple quantities now related
to these particle systems for example
the entropy
so i'm showing you here time versus the
entropy in black we have again for this
harmonic trap behavior we have a
benchmark
orange is our adaptive active learning
approximation which follows quite
accurately the
black benchmark solution
blue is again uninformed sampling which
has no even though there is the
expressiveness of the network there is
no hope of training that accurately with
that few
points at which to minimize the residual
and what we also compared to is digging
monte carlo paths and then using kde as
density estimation and compute entropy
based on that that is this dashed red
curve and there you can see it kind of
gets the trend and i really tuned the
bandwidth of this kernel density
estimator but i could not get a much
better result than than than this here
on the right now i'm showing you
particles in an a harmonic track where
we do not have a benchmark solution
anymore so in that case again time
versus entropy
you can see in orange our neuroglurkin
adaptive sampling solution in red you
can see red dashed you can see what we
get with kde and monte carlo um they
they are kind of agree that there are
oscillations in the entropy which we
know from from the physics of that
problem but um we we are not we don't
have a benchmark to really compare in
terms of accuracy here but what i'm
trying to say is that the entropy we can
get the entropy essentially for free
because we estimate directly the density
instead of just particle positions as
monte carlo would do
all right so with that let me summarize
and and conclude so with this
neuroglurkin idea what we really wanted
to highlight that on the one hand we
need nonlinear parametrizations for
certain types of problems especially
transport dominated ones
to break what's sometimes referred to as
the komogorov barrier and deep networks
are one way to achieve such a nonlinear
parametrization but that is really only
one part of the story the other part of
the story is the training and the
numerically computing with it and here
especially when we are interested in
higher dimensional problems if you're
interested in wave propagation problems
where there's something very local
happening in the spatial domain then i
hope i could convince you that adaptive
sampling active learning could be a tool
that's that quite help that is quite
helpful there to scale this up to higher
dimensions to to enable long time
predictions
okay if you are interested in these kind
of things have a look at our preprint
which is available in archive um i
mentioned this article in the notices of
the american mathematical society um
earlier already it's kind of an
educational article on
on on this overall topic and we also
have other works on non-linear model
reduction that are based on online
adaptive uh basis and spaces rather than
directly non-linear parameterizations
via deep networks so with that um thanks
for your attention and i'm happy to take
questions
thank you thank you so much for the
wonderful talk benjamin um
it was it was really great um let's have
a q a sessions all right we have a
question in chat room by faye
what about the computational course to
offline and online
okay great questions thanks thanks for
asking this so at this point there's no
offline stage
so what this really is um is trying to
do is coming up with a
more efficient full model in some sense
there's no reduction as in a classical
mod reduction setting we're just trying
to describe the transport dominated
dynamics um directly in in in in these
nonlinear parametrizations rather than
on on classical linear ones so what we
really want to compete with are higher
dimensional problems and i mentioned
monte carlo as being one option for
certain types of problems for example
this focal blank equation you can use
monte carlo but for example for really
pure transport
where feminine cac is not it's not
applicable directly you can maybe get
point values with monte carlo as ours
approach really gives you the solution
such as the density or the whole
solution in the spatial domain
all right
andrew
gillett asked
what does high dimension mean in your
opinion uh there seems to be no
consciousness in the world yeah i i
agree with you that there's no consensus
what what that means so in our case um
higher dimensions means when it becomes
really cumbersome to do a uniform
sampling to minimize the residual
and this can be as low as two dimensions
if you have a really local dynamics in
your spatial domain
okay sounds good
um
can you go back to the slide 20
oh 20 okay
well i don't see the slide number let me
move that yeah right there yeah 20 over
yeah
so here um you have a n plus and p
equations and unknowns so np is the
number of unknowns and
no and nte is the number of parameters
right
uh n n is the number of output
points
and
p is the number of features that a unit
depends on
so the alpha i
is p
right in in the neural net context
that's the number of parameters
right that's the that's uh for
right for one output function
okay um
all right
okay
does make sense so that the number of
features
times the the outputs
so if you're if you're asking about how
this grows yes this absolutely grows
with the with the number of weights
depending on the yeah depending on the
neural net uh
yeah um so what sort of
yeah the neural net have you tried
so we have we have really worked with
very
small networks so maybe
up to
50 nodes or something like this which
was sufficient for the examples that we
looked at but i think you're pointing
out a very important um
very important point namely how to
efficiently solve the the corresponding
system
right
this year
if this m matrix grows bigger and bigger
and
i know that some people um here at grant
i'm not necessarily involved in that
they are looking into directions of
having iterative solvers on not really
assembling this m but just doing a
matrix vector version of it um you can
also think of more clever network
architectures to bring down the number
of parameters that you have so all these
classical things that that people are
working on on network compression can
imprints will be applied in that setting
as well even though we don't do that
here there's no hyper reduction or
anything going on because we don't
really have a more expensive model that
we want to reduce
right right
all right so so that's my next question
is
how does the computational cost of
neural garlic method you propose here
with a
some reference solutions you have um
compared to in numerical
uh sections right um
yeah so
i i see that the accuracy is really on
top of each other that's really good
yeah i mean for for these 1d examples we
did not really a cost comparison because
there's not really
they are not really challenging from you
in a classical setting but for example
for this high dimensional problems we
looked at monte carlo runs and it
actually gets quite expensive to have so
many monte carlo paths that you can get
a reasonable density estimation here and
then you not only have to do the monte
carlo you have to do the density
estimation and you have to find the
corresponding parameters so i i did not
i cannot give you a plot now that do the
external comparison but it is
monte carlo in that setting to really
compute for example the entropy is not
just pushing through paths but you have
to do other steps to get the quantities
that one is interested in here
and also qualitatively you see
qualitatively neural um neural collagen
is faster
in
i would say if there's something to make
it faster it is in in this higher
dimensional settings because grid-based
approaches just are not applicable
because of the course of dimensionality
and training over time and space is
challenging because you don't really
know where to put your sampling points
and monte carlo you might need many
samples to get something like a density
and density estimation high dimension is
challenging in different aspects
very good very good is there any other
questions
all
right yeah i don't see anything from the
chat well thank you so much for the
wonderful talk uh
benjamin i really enjoyed it i
definitely
want to go back to your paper and then
learn more about it so
that was good and after this meeting um
hopefully um
you get connected connected by um you
know many other uh the
folks in in lawrence liberal national
lab so that they can
initiate the future collaborations yeah
awesome thank you so much benjamin thank
you very much
again yeah let's stay in touch bye
okay
let me